april the 2nd 2019
algerian president abdel aziz bhutahlir
resigned following weeks of massive
street protests
frail
unable to walk or talk and rarely seen
in public following a stroke he suffered
in 2013
but
bound to pressure from protesters and
the army chief
this is the moment he resigned and
handed over power to the senate speaker
who became the interim head of state
an undignified exit for the man who
played crucial roles in algeria's modern
history
buchalika is considered a national hero
by his supporters
he fought on the battlefield during
algeria's war of independence from
france then
served as foreign minister until 1979.
in the early 1980s he was accused of
corruption and went into self-imposed
exile the charges were later dropped
and at the end of the civil war in the
late 1990s that claimed the lives of
thousands butterflies won an election
with the backing of the military the
opposition said the vote was rigged
buttaflirca won praise for restoring
stability that led to an economic boom
and major development projects
nationwide he also managed to hold the
country together during the arab spring
there were protests in january 2011
against poverty and unemployment the
government responded by creating
thousands of small business
opportunities with generous incentives
to young entrepreneurs reducing food
prices and ending a decades-old state of
emergency
despite the initiatives riots continued
after winning a second mandate in 2004
but africa changed the constitution to
run for a third term
and despite deteriorating health he
changed the constitution once again to
secure a fourth term
western leaders considered him an
important ally in the fight against
armed groups in north africa but
afflicted had zero tolerance towards
al-qaeda and others
his heavy-handedness linked to that
approach is blamed for costing civilian
lives
in 2013
30 foreign workers were killed when
butterflier ordered the army to storm a
gas plant in the algerian desert
the aim was to rescue hundreds of
hostages held by an armed group
affiliated to al-qaeda
critics said the president could have
saved lives had he negotiated a safe
exit for the hostage years or planned
the counter-attack more carefully
but
grip on power started to slip when he
announced his bid to run for a fifth
term in february 2019.
hundreds of thousands of algerians
poured into the streets in the biggest
demonstrations seen since the
independence in 1962
for five weeks the protesters demanded
the president and his allies resign but
first tried to placate protesters by
reversing his decision to stand again
and postponing the election
saying he'd stay on until a new
constitution was adopted
but it wasn't enough to stop the revolt
the protests continued
was sealed when the army chief stepped
in forcing algeria's longest serving
president from power